SAURABH GUPTA: Good afternoon.
And welcome to Building Apps
with Google Apps Script.
My name is Saurabh Gupta, and
I'm the product manager for
Google Apps Script.
And today, I'm going to
tell you a story.
This is a story about an app,
a web app, that was built
using Google Apps Script.
The name of the app is DriveEye,
and it lets you keep
an eye on your Google Drive.
This story has four parts to it,
meaning we'll go through
the whole process of how this
web app was assembled and put
together using Google
Apps Script.
And in each of these sections,
we'll cover in detail as to
what you should do when building
an app like that.
And along the way, we have
a few surprises for you.
But before we begin,
what is DriveEye?
Let me explain a little
bit about DriveEye.
So as I said, DriveEye
lets you keep an eye
on your Google Drive.
So for example if, say, you
have a shared folder, and
you're sharing it, say, with
your friend, or colleague, or
whoever, right?
And if there is some activity in
that folder, meaning files
get added to that folder, then
you might want to get some
notifications on it.
So DriveEye lets you just do
exactly that, which is lets
you keep an eye on your drive
on a particular folder.
So the first thing is when you
go to this web app, you can
subscribe to notifications
from different
folders in your drive.
So it's a simple way of adding
folders that you can have
subscription to.
Once you have subscription, then
if, say, there is some
activity in this folder-- so for
example in this screenshot
here you see I have subscribed
to activity in,
say, playoff bets.
And if a friend of mine added
a file or a spreadsheet into
the folder, then I get an email
saying, hey, somebody
added a file to this folder,
or something like that.
So it's a very simple, yet
powerful app that lets you
keep an eye on your drive.
And this was built using
Google Apps Script.
So a little bit of history of
Apps Script and our origin.
So we started in 2009 as a way
of letting you write custom
functions and spreadsheets.
Simple, yet powerful features.
Along the way, we said,
well, you can
write custom functions.
Why not some interesting UI,
and sort of extend your
spreadsheet experience?
We also gave you a little
gallery where you can share
code and share your
scripts as well.
And last year, we doubled down
on our investment in UI.
Gave you UIBuilder and a whole
host of services that you can
use to write and build
awesome apps.
So what's for this year?
Well, what we thought was that
what we had built was
something really good.
But of course, this is Google,
so we want to do something
even better.
And that better is
script.google.com.
This is a one-stop
shop for all your
Google Apps Script needs.
This the place that you go now
to create, manage, organize,
write your scripts.
One simple URL script,
script.google.com.
Don't forget it.
Again, I'll say
script.google.com.
So what does script.google.com
let you do?
And this is the first part of
our story, which is it lets
you create scripts.
Now, what's such a big deal
about creating scripts?
Well, I'm going to walk you
through as to the big deal
about creating scripts, but the
short answer is, you can
now create scripts from your
Google Drive, or you can
create scripts from
script.google.com.
So again, did anything change
with script.google.com?
No.
If you like the way Apps
Script is today--
or was until yesterday, you
get all those features.
You get all your APIs,
your services.
You get all your events,
triggers, and a whole host of
functionality.
But with script.google.com, you
get something even more.
So what's such a big deal about
this whole create part
of the story on DriveEye?
Well, we let you create scripts,
but only from sites
or spreadsheets.
So a lot of our users
ask us, like why are
you hiding this product?
And we used to say, well,
you can create
container-bound scripts.
That was our origin.
But with script.google.com,
now you no longer have to
create a spreadsheet
to create a script.
Projects are independent and
are, in their own right, first
class developer products.
And scripts.google.com
is your destination.
So this is the first feature
that we are launching today
which is letting you create
standalone scripts, scripts
that can be created from
Google Drive, or
script.google.com.
So let's explore some
differences between
container-bond scripts and
standalone scripts.
As we know, container-bound
scripts can be created from
Spreadsheet in the Tools menu,
and you can go to the Script
Editor and you can create as
many scripts as you like.
And they are bound to a
spreadsheet, and those are
container-bound scripts.
But as you can see in this
screenshot here, you can now
create scripts from the drive
itself, Google Drive.
Go to Create Menu and More,
you will see Script.
And now, once you create a
script, it will show up in
your drive as well.
Well, if you go to
script.google.com, then you
see a Welcome screen, and you
are well on your way to
creating standalone scripts.
These scripts will also
show up in your drive.
Another difference,
container-bound scripts always
followed the life cycle of the
parent or the container.
So for example, if you had a
script that was part of a
spreadsheet, it lived and died
with the spreadsheet.
Standalone scripts, on the other
hand, live on their own.
So they have their life cycle.
That's an easy difference.
How do you find container-bound
scripts?
So you have to locate the
parent, which is, first, you
have to go to a spreadsheet,
then find all
the attached scripts.
But standalone scripts
just show up in your
drive, just like that.
You can go to your drive or UI,
and go through all your
script projects.
Well, if you like search, you
can actually search your code
in Google Drive, and script
projects will show up.
So how many of you have this
myFunction script that you
play it around with, and you
can just type myFunction in
there, and you will see all
of these scripts that have
myFunction in it?
So not only can you create
scripts from Drive or
script.google.com, but you can
find them there, and you can
search for code, so all your
needs around creating and
finding scripts are
taken care of.
So going back to our application
which is DriveEye,
how does this whole create
story fit in?
Well, in order to design this
application, DriveEye, we
thought, well, we will
need to create
three standalone projects.
The first project is the main
DriveEye project, which has
all the nice UI and
everything.
The second would be a folder
subscription API, meaning if I
want to subscribe to a folder,
I want to remove a
subscription, things like,
then I should be able to
create a project that can do
those types of things.
And then eventually, there is a
data model that needs to be
stored in some database.
That's pretty complex
stuff here.
But the bottom line is
we need to create
three standalone projects.
But then, before we start
creating the standalone
projects, what is the best way
to build UI and store data?
And again, let's go back to
our history a little bit.
So we let you create scripts
from spreadsheets.
And we had UIApp, an awesome way
to build UI, and a great
way to store data.
That was pretty good, right?
But this is Google.
We want to do something
even better.
So today, we are announcing
ScriptDB, which is your
one-stop shop for all your
data storing needs for
scripts, and HTMLService.
So now, you can use HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS, and
create web applications.
So if you don't like the way to
create applications using
Google Web Toolkit style, then
you can use HTMLService.
And this session is not really
about ScriptDB or HTMLService.
But we have two awesome
sessions tomorrow.
One covering ScriptDB, and this
is at 5:15, room number
seven, Drew's session.
So you should definitely
attend that.
You will learn lots
of new stuff.
It's fully packed with
functionality.
Every script gets
a data store.
It's a JSON data store.
You can store your JavaScript
objects, search across them,
do a whole host of things.
And we thought you needed a
whole session to understand
the full capabilities of it.
So do remember, 5:15 PM,
room number seven.
And HTML Service, again,
very powerful stuff.
It's not just able to do HTML,
JavaScript, CSS, but there's a
lot of other functionality
like templates,
and things like that.
So definitely attend
this session as
well, 2:45, room 11.
But let's get back to
our session about
building this app.
So as we have noted, we needed
three standalone projects.
So we go about creating three
standalone projects.
And you can see here, we have
these three standalone
projects created in our drive.
And this is the data model that
we want to use, so these
are the JavaScript objects that
eventually will be stored
in ScriptDB.
But the first class is the user
class, which when a user
subscribes to a folder,
a trigger gets
created for the user.
And we keep track of what
folders you want to subscribe
on, and the files, and
things like that.
All of this gets stored
in ScriptDB.
And for the folder subscription
API, we implement
all of these functions where
you can add subscription,
remove, and things like that.
Pretty simple stuff, right?
So now, we have the ability to
create scripts, standalone
strips, from script.google.com,
and we have
created three standalone
projects.
But how do we glue these three
projects together?
What should we do?
And that brings us to the second
part of the story,
which is, we want to make it
easy for you to share your
scripts so that you can
collaborate and
organize your code.
So let's go back to
our history again.
So we had some sort of
sharing and scripts.
Like you can create a script
from a spreadsheet, and you
can share it in a way you can
allow editors to collaborate
on your script, and
things like that.
Again, that was pretty good,
but we want to do better.
And that better is just
a plain, simple
way of sharing scripts.
And what could be easier than
sharing scripts but sharing in
a Google Docs way?
And if you're familiar with this
dialog, then you would
know that this is how you share
your documents, this is
how you share a spreadsheet,
this is how you share you
presentations.
So why not share your scripts
using the same, well-known
ability to share?
So let's explore a little bit
about how sharing works.
So as we know, we have two types
of scripts, standalone
scripts and container-bound
scripts.
So what we have done is we have
made sharing easy, such
that container-bound scripts
inherit all the permissions
from the parent.
So if you create a spreadsheet,
and then you
create a script, that script
would get all the permissions
from the spreadsheet.
Very simple.
There is no complex way of,
like, OK, I want to prevent
editors, and things like that.
Simple way to understand
inheritance of permission.
For standalone scripts, you can
use this dialog and add
viewers and editors.
So a very simple, well-known,
well-used way of sharing.
But we have another concept in
scripts, which is, you need to
give execute permission.
So what we have done is we
have made all viewers
executors as well.
So if you can give view
permission to a script, then
you're giving execute
permissions as well.
And comparing this analogy
to libraries, or JARs, or
whatever, if I can get a JAR,
then I can pretty much execute
whatever code I have
in that JAR.
So OK, that's great.
I can share my scripts.
That's fine.
I can invite more viewers,
editors.
People can look at my code.
That's fine.
But how does it help me to
really organize my code?
And so we said, well, we
launched Libraries last month.
And Libraries is that higher
order of sharing, which is
once you share your script, then
somehow, what if there
existed some magic where you
could covert your script
project into a library?
And that's that higher
order of sharing.
So how do you create
a library?
It's three simple steps
to create a library.
You save a version
of your script.
Then you share the script
with view permission.
So once you have invited
viewers to your script
project, then you are almost
halfway there.
Now, your collaborators
can view your code.
But then, when you share your
project key, then they can
really start using your script
project as a library.
So going back to our DriveEye
project, what we need to do is
we need to convert two projects
out of these three to
libraries, and then use them.
So what we are going to do is
we're going to take the Data
Model project, create a library
out of it, and then
use that as a library in the
second project, which is the
Folder Subscription Library.
And then make Folder
Subscription project as a
library, and then use it
in the main project.
It's pretty complex stuff, but
it goes to show the power of
sharing, combined with
libraries, the kinds of things
that you can do here.
So how do you use a library?
Well, four simple steps.
Once you have got that project
key from the owner or the
author of the library, you
insert their project key in
the Manage Libraries dialog
that you can see
in the script editor.
And once you do that, then
you can select a version.
So now, remember you saved the
version, so you can have
multiple versions at the same
time of your library.
And whoever wants to
use your library
can choose the version.
Once you choose a version,
then you are asked for an
identifier.
Now this identifier is sort of
the namespace that you will
give to that library
in your code.
Here, for our DriveEye
application, we are using the
name, FolderAlertLib, and I am
going to show you how this is
used in the code.
And that's the last step really,
which is once I open
up my script editor, I
include the library.
And as soon as I type my
identifier or the namespace--
and here in this case, it's
FolderAlertLib.--
you can see the auto-complete
shows up with all the
available functions
that this library
provides for that version.
Four simple ways to
create libraries.
And again, this example shows
you how a data model library
was used in the second
project.
Here you can see
DataModel.DriveFolder and
DriveFolder was one of
the main classes that
we wanted to store.
So it's very simple
and easy to create
libraries and use them.
And it helps you organize
your code.
Because now, you can refactor
your code such that it becomes
usable chunks.
And then, you can publish
versions and [? help ?] create
libraries, and then continue
working on your code.
So you can collaborate
effectively, you can
organize your code.
It's a really higher
form of sharing.
And again, as I said, we used
FolderAlertLib, and we are
using this library in the main
project, the DriveEye project,
that has the UI as well.
So we talked about creating
scripts from Drive or
script.google.com.
We talked about sharing
scripts.
We talked about creating
libraries.
We talked about creating three
standalone projects,
converting them into
libraries, gluing them together.
So we have all the
elements now.
What's next?
So assuming all the
code is done.
We have glued together
everything.
Then we need to be able
to deploy our
script as a web app.
And that's the third part of our
story, which is we want to
make it easy for you to creates
script projects, share
them, organize your code,
and then, able to
deploy them as web apps.
Now, deploying scripts as web
apps is not something that is
new to Apps Script.
We have had this for awhile.
And let me explain to you a
little bit about how web apps
used to work, or work today
in Apps Script.
So imagine if I have a
developer, and his name is
Bob, and he writes an
awesome web app.
And say this is an event
management web app where he
wrote a web app, and all users
need to see the event
calendar, or a list of events,
or something like that.
So it uses Bob's data, Bob's
spreadsheet, all the event
information.
Everything is in there.
And then, he writes the script,
and then converts that
into a web app.
And the user comes along--
let's call him Sam--
and Sam uses the web app.
So in app script lingo, Sam
becomes the active user,
meaning the user on
the keyboard.
And when Sam accesses the web
app, the script runs.
And the script runs as Bob,
because the script is supposed
to access Bob's data.
And Bob, in Apps Script terms,
is the effective user.
And this worked pretty well,
but there were some
limitations to it.
It was pretty good.
It was well-received, but
obviously, we wanted to do
something even better.
And that better is a new way
of deploying web apps.
So let's go back to our diagram
a little bit, and try
to understand what is this new
way of deploying web apps?
So imagine if we had this app,
but now, instead of the script
running as developer Bob, what
if it runs as Sam, and
accesses Sam's data?
Of course, with his permission,
authorization, and
all security, everything
taken care of.
But if the script could run as
Sam, the user, then all of a
sudden, we have a whole host of
new use cases that open up
with web apps written
using script.
And in this case, the active
user, which was Sam, is also
the effective user.
The effective user is a
service-side concept in Apps
Script, where it's the identity
under which a script
runs on the server.
So this is the new way of
deploying web apps.
So what are some of the
advantages of this
new type of web app?
Well, the first advantage, as I
just demonstrated, was that
now the scripts are more
powerful, because the web apps
are powerful, because
they can ask
access to user's resources.
For example--
and user here being the
user on the keyboard--
user's calendar, spreadsheets,
and all that.
And for DriveEye this
is really important.
And the reason why this is
important is because when I,
as a user of DriveEye, access
DriveEye, I want to DriveEye
to show my folders.
I want to place a subscription
on folders that belong to me,
not to the developer.
So this is really important.
And the second reason why this
is useful is because now, you
can get the identity
of the active user,
the user on the keyboard.
With the earlier type of web
apps, you could not get the
identity of the active user.
And the third and really
interesting thing here is that
the script, when it runs as the
new type of web app, it
uses the end user's quota.
So as a developer, if you create
a really useful app,
then it's not limited to just
your quota, or the use of the
app is just not limited
to your quota.
It is limited to the end user,
the user on the keyboard.
So all these three factors make
it really compelling,
that this type of new way of
deploying web app becomes
pretty compelling.
Again, just to clarify, the type
of web app that we had
was the first type, which was
the active user is the end
user, and developer is
the effective user.
The new of deploying web apps
is active user and effective
user are the same, which is
the user on the keyboard.
So how do you deploy these
types of web apps?
Well, as this dialogue really
shows, you can select the type
of web app here, and select
whether you want the web app
to run as you as the developer,
or as the user
accessing the web app.
And this simple selection
is the choice of
deployment that you have.
Not only that, as you are
familiar with, you can control
access like who can access
this web app.
And we added something even
better which was making it
easy for you to productionize
your application.
Which is, you can now save your
web apps as versions and
then select the version.
So why is that really useful?
Well, the reason why this is
really useful is that you want
one single, immutable URL
for your web apps.
You don't want to change the
URL under your users.
However you still want the
flexibility to test your app.
You want to continue development
of your web app.
So what you can do is you can
save your web apps as
versions, and then assign the
version number to the URL.
And whenever a user is accessing
your web app, then
the assigned version script
will be executed.
And you can continue developing
without impacting
the user at all.
So it makes it very easy to
productionize your web
application, and it makes it
very easy for you to continue
developing, testing, and
all the good stuff.
So deploying web apps is easy.
It's the same doGet.
But here you see a little
teaser here, which is
HTMLService.
And I'm not going to delve in
more details, because you
should attend tomorrow's
session at 2:45.
But the whole idea is now you
can do a lot more with
HTML5Service, and HTML,
JavaScript, CSS, and create
very interesting web apps.
One on the other interesting
parts of the DriveEye
application is that because it's
going to send you alerts
on activity on a particular
folder, it needs to create a
trigger on behalf of the user.
So the flow here is that when
the user of DriveEye first
subscribes to a folder, the web
app creates a trigger on
behalf of the user.
And this is easy now because
we have that other way of
deploying web apps.
So as you can see, we use the
recently launched ScriptApp
service to create a trigger
which runs for every five
minutes, polls the user's drive,
and compares and sees
if there are new files or not.
And this is only possible
because now you can deploy new
types of web apps.
So how do users find
your web apps?
Well, one way is that you
can create a URL and
distribute a URL.
But how many users can you
reach with your URL?
And this brings us to the last
part of our story here, which
is, we want to make it easy for
you to publish your web
apps in a way that it
is discoverable.
So publishing is not
new to Apps Script.
We had the Script Gallery, but
it was more of a way of
sharing code amongst
developers.
It was not really a mechanism
where apps could be
discovered, and stored
and installed.
So that was good.
It really serves its purpose,
but we want to do, again,
something really, really good.
And so we are launching
integration
with Chrome Web Store.
Now you can publish your web
apps in Chrome Web Store.
So you ask, what is the big
deal about publishing in
Chrome Web Store?
Well, you have the URL, you
can publish it yourself.
But what we have done is we have
made it really simple to
publish in Chrome Web Store.
It takes one click uploads
to Chrome web store.
So we take care of the packaging
and all the initial
upload part of the
Chrome Web Store.
And also, we let you easily
verify your web apps, because
your web apps will be running
on script.google.com.
So it's really important
that you verify
ownership of your web apps.
So these are the two reasons,
I think, why it's pretty
interesting that we have Chrome
Web Store integration
for you guys.
So it's, again, four simple
steps in making your web apps
available in Chrome Web Store.
First is verify your
ownership using
Google Webmaster Central.
And it's a, really, two-step
process guided from the script
editor on script.google.com.
So it's very straightforward
and simple.
Then, what you do is you click
on Publish and register with
Chrome Web Store, and you
get this dialogue here.
And you can just click on
Register Web App, and we have
taken care of all the packaging
requirements for
Chrome Web Store.
And then, you can go to Chrome
App Store and customize your
listing, meaning you can provide
icons, screenshots,
YouTube videos, [? tiles ?],
whatever it takes to make our
app look so pretty that
everybody wants to install it.
And once you've customized your
listing, you just publish
and go live.
And that's it.
Your web apps are now available
in Chrome Web Store.
So this really completes
our story.
We want to make it easy for
you to create scripts from
Drive or script.google.com, and
we want to make it easy
for you to share scripts,
organize your code, use
Library, use code.
We want to make it easy
for you to deploy
scripts as web apps.
And eventually, allow you to
publish scripts in Chrome Web
Store, so that millions
of users can benefit
from your web app.
So time for a quick demo.
So this is a demo of DriveEye
and how it works.
So let's get started.
So I go to Chrome Web Store,
and you will see a
listing like this.
And I obviously did not
customize my listing really
well, because there should be,
like, good screenshot, but
this is how your listing
should look like.
So once you go to the
Chrome web store,
you say Add to Chrome.
Then you will get a dialogue,
and then it will show up in
your Chrome New Tab, next to my
little Angry Birds there.
And once it shows up on my
Chrome New Tab, then I get an
email that I have installed
this app.
And what this email says is it
gives you, like, instruction
about what DriveEye is, and
what authorizations have I
granted, and things like that.
It's pretty simple.
It's just a reminder.
So once you install the app, and
it shows up in the Chrome
New Tab, then let's access
this app and have a
little fun with it.
Like, let's add a few folders
that I want to be alerted on.
Of course, playoff bets is
really important, tax returns
for some reason, and images.
And I am an avid racquetball
player, so some racquetball
league stuff.
So now what I've done is I
have subscribed to a few
folders that exist
in my drive.
Now, but all of these
are really good.
I'm interested in racquetball,
yeah, images,
yeah, returns, of course.
But what I'm really interested
in is cocktails.
And I know a friend of
mine, I mean, he
really is into cocktails.
And I don't to miss out on any
new stuff that he does.
So what I say is, hey, I
tell my friend Sam--
he keeps a folder of
cocktail recipes--
and I ask him, you should share
this folder with me.
So I'm like, OK.
So he does and he shares
this folder with me.
And as you can see, he uses
the same sharing.
It's folder sharing, a
Google Drive, and he
shares it with me.
Once he shares this folder
with me, I get an email.
It's a standard Google Drive
email saying a folder is
shared with me.
And you can see Sam
shared this folder
with cocktail recipes.
And it has some cocktails
in there already.
So I go back to my DriveEye and
add CocktailRecipes as the
folder that I want to be alerted
on so that I will no
longer now miss out on the
adventures of my friend Sam.
And I know, well, he keeps
coming up with
new cocktail recipes.
So one day, something
will happen.
And that did happen.
So Sam here created two
new cocktails, right?
So Bond in the Taj Mahal.
It was like, OK, Taj Mahal is
in my hometown, so why not?
Like, I really want this.
And then Thirsty
in Monte Carlo.
Well, gambling and cocktails,
that's an awesome combination.
So I want that.
So he selects these two,
and then drags
them into this folder.
So once he does that, in five
minutes, I get an email
saying, hey, there are two files
that are added here in
this folder.
And now I get notified
on that folder.
So it helps me keep an eye on
my drive, on my folders, and
it helps me keep an eye on what
my friends are doing so
that I don't miss out
on good stuff.
So going back.
So if I wanted to remember two
things out of this entire
session, it's this slide
and then the next one.
So this slide is
pretty simple.
Six new main features
in Apps Script.
Ability to create standalone
scripts.
ScriptDB, you should definitely
attend the session tomorrow.
HTMLService, again, you should
definitely attend that session.
Sharing scripts in
a simple way.
Deploying new types
of web apps.
Integration with Chrome
app store.
And the one last thing that
you need to remember is
script.google.com.
And I'm opening it
up for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
How will you handle
authorization and
authentication?
Do we need to enable the APIs
we're accessing on the
Dashboard or something
like we usually do?
For example, if I want to get
access to [? Contacts ?]
Drive, need to enable
those APIs in
the Developer Dashboard?
SAURABH GUPTA: So if I
understand your question,
you're asking how do you turn
on authorization and
authentication on some
of the APIs?
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
SAURABH GUPTA: Awesome
question.
So this is Google Apps Script.
"Apps" in the name is
there for a reason.
And that reason is that we take
care of security for all
of your apps products.
So if you are writing a script
and you're going to the script
editor, you are already
logged in.
And then when the script runs,
it runs under somebody's
account, like security
contact.
So it either runs as
you, or run as the
active user, whatever.
So a lot of that security, or
OAuth stuff is taken care of
already, so you don't have to
deal with it when using
default services
of Apps Script.
All you have to do is just
authorize that, yeah, you want
a script to access
some of these
resources on your behalf.
But as a developer, you
don't have to worry
about OAuth at all.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SAURABH GUPTA: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First, congratulations.
This new feature
seems amazing.
SAURABH GUPTA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: With these standalone
scripts, will we be
able to manage these scripts
via Google Drive SDK?
You know, change the
script code, and--?
SAURABH GUPTA: So let me
understand your question.
So what you're saying is you
want to manage these scripts
using Drive SDK.
Now, I think what you're talking
about is the Drive
API, the Docs List API, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SAURABH GUPTA: So the answer
is, eventually.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
That was really exciting.
A great talk.
Thank you.
Question.
On the effective user being the
person using the script,
are there any fallback
provisions for if they don't
have a Google account, or don't
log in, where you could
fall back to your resources
running it?
Or is it just one
or the other?
They have to have a Google
account, or if they don't--
could you deploy an app that
uses their account if they've
got one, or if they don't,
you fall back
to something yourself?
SAURABH GUPTA: So, again,
rephrasing your question, what
you want is you want to have the
script access the account
of the user who's using
the web app, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
SAURABH GUPTA: So this
is the new thing
that we launched today.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but if that
person doesn't have a Google
account, they can't
access your--
SAURABH GUPTA: So yeah.
The person needs to have
a Google account.
Yeah.
You need to have a Google
account to create scripts and
use scripts in a
meaningful way.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
If the class that you're after
isn't available within Google
Apps Script, and you have to
go after, for example, the
Resources API, and now I have
to expose within my script a
client key that's secret,
is there a way to--
you mentioned view gives
you execute?
Can I have execute
with no view?
SAURABH GUPTA: So when you
deploy as web app, and it's
the new type of web app that we
talked about, then you do
not share your code.
If the question is how do you
protect your secret key, then
you can totally do that.
But if you use that code as a
reusable library, then you
have to share the library.
And in that case, it
is not protected.
AUDIENCE: Well, in order for
the code to run against the
resource API, you have
to authenticate
outside of Google Apps.
So you have to actually make
a call like a URL fetch.
SAURABH GUPTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: So how would you
protect that code?
SAURABH GUPTA: So there are
some challenges in there.
And I can tell you that we
putting a lot of effort in
improving the whole
URL fetch thing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
SAURABH GUPTA: So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: To include use
of your own domain?
OK, would that include users
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Howdy, Congrats.
We get a lot of utility out of
the UI elements that are in
the spreadsheet environment.
So the additional dropdown
menus, and whatnot.
Can what you're describing
around deploying as a web app
produce UIs in the Spreadsheet
environment, or are they
purely standalone UIs?
SAURABH GUPTA: So the new UI
is also in the Spreadsheet
environment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if I understand correctly,
if I'm a user, and I want to
add functionality to a
spreadsheet, and have
additional menus in my
spreadsheet, I would go to the
web app, choose the spreadsheet
I want to install
it on, and then from there
on out, it would--
SAURABH GUPTA: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: --function
identically to a
container-bound script?
SAURABH GUPTA: The distribution
of scripts into a
spreadsheet remains the
same way through
the gallery for now.
The Chrome web store integration
piece that we have
added is for web apps.
But if you want to use, say,
HTMLService in your
spreadsheet, then you're going
to write the script in the
same way you wrote the script,
but use HTMLService, and then
distribute either through
Gallery, or through a
copy/paste mechanism and get
those scripts into your
spreadsheet.
Is that what your question?
AUDIENCE: We'll talk
more, yeah.
SAURABH GUPTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: Great stuff.
Congratulations to you
and your team.
My question is, if you actually
share a script with a
bunch of people with an Apps
account, is that script also--
you know how in sites, you
can also insert scripts--
is that the same sharings if
you've shared with the Apps
account user, basically
they can add it to
their sites as well?
SAURABH GUPTA: So scripts that
can be added in a site's page
are container-bound scripts.
They have to be created
from a Google site.
Now, what you can do is, though,
say, if you have some
reusable code, and you want to
use it in different scripts in
a site's page, then you can
create a standalone project in
your drive and, create
a library.
And then use that library in a
script that belongs to a site.
So what you do is you basically
factor your code and
take out the reusable parts of
it, and have that code live as
a standalone project,
and then use it
everywhere as a library.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Got it.
And is the code available
for this demo?
SAURABH GUPTA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: We really just wanted
to build something like
that, so I kind of want
to take this code.
SAURABH GUPTA: Yes.
So we will definitely link to
the store item, and as well as
the code, and when the
announcement goes out
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
SAURABH GUPTA: Well, if there
are no more questions, thank
you, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
And we are here to help on our
office hours and everything.
Thank you.